Okay.
Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn. It's
the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
August 3rd, 2050 what's
going on out? Whoa.
Okay.
Oh, can you believe it's already
August 3rd? Where is the summer going?
No need to fret everyone because now
that we are in the golden age of global
warming, you know right before
all the bad shit happens.
The great thing is is summer goes right
through to like October at this point.
So there's still time to
get your beach body lay
and gentlemen.
Um,
you don't really helps with you.
You have,
you just get depressed at how quickly
life is going by how quickly time is going
by. You know, what really helps that
is if you're working towards something.
Okay.
I swear to God and I tried to get
all fucking goofy here in self help.
I'm actually excited for August to end
to get right through this month because I
know where I'm going to
be. Cause I, I had been,
oh I've been working out today.
I stepped on the scale and my goal
was to get, go for one 80 to one 77,
dropped by three pounds by the fucking
week. I go to the gym every day,
just be calm.
And you know,
every day you can't.
Wow. Um, I got on,
I got on the scale babbled
laptop when I got out of bed, um,
on the scale this morning.
And uh,
I weighed in at one 76.4 or point Pfoa
is some people say in Massachusetts or
basically the new England area
once every 6.46 ounces to spare.
I'm pretty psyched about that.
Um,
what I did this week was I just kept
eating the exact same way that I've been
eating. Uh, which is, is perfect
as I know how to eat. You know,
there's only so much you can
read about nutrition, you know,
about good carbohydrate, a good
fats, bad fats, good cholesterol,
bad cholesterol, fucking
glycerin, whatever the fuck it is.
I just a glucose and all that shit. I
just love, I just shut up. All right.
With your, your, your words. You know, I,
I, those fucking words don't excite me.
They don't make me go, oh, what's
the next sentence going to read?
I've got to figure out how to get
excited about reading about nutrition.
You know, I just can't, I cannot get
into reading about nuts and berries,
you know what I mean? There's no
car chase. There's no Teddy's,
there's no classic lines.
Snow, snow, shiny suits him.
Well, well, there's nothing.
What is their way of for me?
Okay.
You know, like sitting through
of some fucking movie, you know,
you didn't want to see,
but you fucked up in your relationships.
So you trying to repair it. See like,
all right, all right, I'll fucking, uh,
oh yeah, let's go see this movie. What
is, what is it called? What is it called?
Seven suppers in September.
What I'm thinking about
dinner dates, divine, whatever
the fuck it's going to be.
Anyways,
but I switched up the cardio this week.
I went to the gym and I skipped
a rope a couple of times,
so it was a different kind of cardio. So
my body's still like, hey, whoa, whoa.
What the fuck's going on? You
know, because I overheard somebody,
you say you're supposed to confuse your
body every light color three to six
weeks. So I did that. And it's
working for me. It's working for me.
Oh boy, boy. And I'm psyched
that I'm losing weight, but, uh,
this is the time and because I'm
recording this on Sunday night and, uh,
it's about, I dunno, seven, eight o'clock.
I didn't know what the fuck time it is.
And, uh, this is the time of night
where I usually a crack open a cold one,
and I'm not, I'm 28 days in
29 when you hear this, and,
uh, you know, so now I'm not craving
alcohol. I don't give a fuck about it.
I'm going to give a shit, but
like, I'm not like, you know,
I'm used to my new lifestyle,
you know,
this is it just wide awake.
Oh, fucking brain cells, straight align,
all counted for Jesus
Christ. I'm bored shitless,
fucking bored shitless, but I am working
towards a few things. I took my first, uh,
um, autorotation, uh,
advanced autorotation class and I fucking
loved it and I felt like I became,
I got like 30% better Adam in one lesson
and I'm just going to keep taking those
fucking things until I can simulate a,
a engine failure and landed like
essentially in a parking spot.
And once I do that, then I'm
going to feel like, all right,
now I feel comfortable the fly around,
take some passengers and that
type of shit. That's what you do.
You don't get your license and then
go, wow, I get it. Pass the bucket.
Let me just fly around and hope nothing
happens. That's not what you do.
You keep going, you keep
learning. Keep trying.
Um,
fuck.
28 days in 72 days was 72 months,
28,
that's 52 minus eight, 44,
44 days to go. Ah, I'm,
I'm rapidly approaching the halfway point,
which is 36 days was 28,
seven 35 shit,
that feels hoping next week I was gonna
be at the halfway point. Who's kidding?
Who People.
I'm going to come off.
I'm going to drop about 20 pounds and I
am going to come off this fucking this
stretch and no Busan and I'm going to
pull it on least 30 pounds. Just a booze.
Wait, forget about all the dump food
choices I want to make when I'm hammered.
Um, now Jesus. So anyways, once
76.4 there, you got to swallow.
I got to do is lose 2.4 this week.
I don't give a fuck.
I just got to plow through
this fucking week, you know,
cause then I'll be down to one 74
and then it gets exciting. Right.
Then you start getting into the low one
seventies and that's basically, you know,
that's where, you know, when my person,
so I could go out and get a headshot
and maybe a book, a cheerios commercial.
That's an exciting way to be at.
You know what I mean? Oh, you go,
you sit there and laugh. Those toasted
that commercials. They fucking pay.
I did one a long time ago. I think it's
up on Youtube. Uh, if you search for it.
Such search whole a Billy red
face toasted owes no, I'm kidding.
I never did one of those,
but I wasn't a honeycomb commercial
when I was just a kid. Honey Cosby. Yay.
Yeah, it's not smile and I wasn't
in that shit either. Um, anyways,
let's get on with the podcast
here. So, uh, that's the deal.
Trying to get in shape,
you know what I mean?
Because I'm not a young fella anymore.
And uh,
if anything tells me that is when fucking,
you know,
heroes of mine from when I
was a kid die in this sleep.
Fucking devastating news of Rod Rowdy
Roddy Piper passing away this week. Man,
I couldn't believe he was fucking 61.
I couldn't really was that old.
And I also was thinking like,
that's 14 years away from me and 14,
14 years you can die in your sleep.
Like that can happen.
And everybody's okay with that, you know,
like, oh, you know, no, not okay with it.
I mean, they miss the guy
and shit. But anyways, so
breast and peace, Rowdy Roddy Piper.
Thank you for all the fucking labs.
Piper's pit man. That was the best. Just
when they think they know the answers,
I changed the questions.
I got to meet him a couple of times when
I was down in the comedy store. And, uh,
it had a chance to hang out with them
one time and I didn't because he was that
big a deal for me.
And I didn't want to know him too well
because he was such a big fucking deal.
That's when I'm telling you before
the Rock and stone cold, Steve Austin,
which was definitely a golden age,
and I think the rock is the
best guy ever on the Mike.
Other than fucking ric flair. That's what
I, my own personal opinion, whatever.
But, um, before the golden age of the
Rock Stone Cold Steve Austin, mankind,
um, um, oh, who's the guy
with the fuck was he called? I just
know what the rock used to call him.
Used to call them the red. You
know what? Ah, what was his name?
I forget anyways,
in the 80s.
Was it cane? Something like that.
I can't fucking remember. Um,
Rowdy Roddy,
Piper sergeant slaughter,
Mr Wonderful.
Jimmy superfly snuck a
I, fuck. I used to watch all of that
shit. Larry's a Bisco. Tony. Gloria,
ted DBRC, Greg the hammer.
Valentine Ivan put ski.
Pat Patterson.
Who else?
The end of Bruno San Martino.
And now there was a red headed fellow
there who had the belt with the fuck was
his name? Uh, Bob Backlund.
MMM.
How Colgan Andre the giant.
The Iron Sheik
George the animal Steele.
Yeah,
the fucking moon dogs.
Okay.
Mr Fuji and Mr Tsai. Edo.
The men of the wild Samoans.
Captain Lou Albano. Freddie Blassie,
the grand wizard of wrestling.
I used to watch that shit
every fucking week. I loved it.
And one of the biggest parts of when,
when fucking Rowdy Roddy Piper
came on the scene, it was like,
who the fuck is this guy came out and
that kilt and from day one was talking,
she was one of those guys.
Steve g showed up and he was a star.
It seemed like it was just overnight.
He was so good.
You couldn't remember wrestling without
a man. And I can't believe that man,
61 years old, he looked great too.
When I saw him, fuck it. Look Great.
Terror of that. I mean I'm getting to
that age whether that's gets terrifying,
like how old was he? What the
fuck? So, uh, anyways, um,
yeah,
yes.
They may start to make me feel old so
I feel good that I'm actually working
towards some shit. So, Oh, Billy fucking
20 hobbies here. So I'm working on those,
uh,
auto rotations and I actually started
taking drum lessons again cause I'm sick
of fucking flailing around the kid.
Nah.
You know,
I was always a,
I always admired guys that had debt,
that fucking flawless technique and I
think c and Keith Carlock when he played
with the steely Dan and just watching the,
obviously no matter how
much technique I have,
I'm never going to play like that guy.
But just watching,
mmm.
Him just effortlessly go around the
kit and the sticks are doing the work.
He's just guiding it with this
hand. It's just fun. It's,
it's really some drunk geek shit, but
it's fucking unreal. And having said that,
does anybody know who was Jim Croce?
His Drummer?
Does anybody have any of the idea? I'm
trying to figure out who played on that.
Working at the car wash blues,
which is really, you know,
it's kind of a Corny fucking song. Who's
kid? No, but the drums on it are there.
Shit,
I love the drums on that fucking song.
And I finally figured out
that little fucking, uh,
I'll play a little something for you.
This is a little fucking press role
that the guide does in the beginning.
I'll say, where the hell is
it? Come on. Oh, here we go.
There it is coming up right now,
right?
Yeah.
Oh, I fucking love that. And two,
three and add one.
But bad at that.
I've been sitting in my fuck.
Just like if the fucking rain man,
trying to figure that thing out.
And I started taking lessons in, uh,
my teacher helped me out with the sham,
but I'm just so I suck at it, but I know,
I know physically how to do it.
So I just got you just sit there and
you do it a million times. Who knows?
Maybe I'll bust that song out at the,
uh, the comedy jam. Little Jim Croce.
God Damn it.
That guy's got some depressing songs,
Huh?
New York is not my home.
Okay.
And I learned a lot of lessons and they
will not the NASCAR kind it all the
shitty things about fucking sleeping
in a doorway, getting mugged,
having to call his parents
that New York's not my home.
I just started singing that.
Don't you know that I
gotta get Outta here?
I'm so low.
Don't you know that I gotta
get hottie because New York's
not my home.
Thank God I never knew that song existed
when I first moved to New York and was
eating my balls at the old Boston comedy
club. I would've gone home crying.
That was that early 70 shit.
They were not about bringing people up.
They would just sit in it, sit
in that depression, you know,
he's got a couple, he's
got, I got a name, you know,
lack of pine trees
lining the winding road.
I've got a name,
I got name sat.
The song doesn't make any sense.
Like to sing and burden the croaking toad.
I've got a name that neither one of
those animals has really as a name,
unless it's a pet. Other than
that, it's just called what it is.
That'd be like if your name
was human being, right?
Yeah.
Yeah. Maybe we should just sit back and
enjoy this song. I don't fucking know,
but I just,
you know,
and I carry it with me like my daddy did.
And even then it gets said, but I'm
living the dream that he couldn't give.
What did that mean?
He drank away his paycheck every week.
It was just fucking good Lord guys putting
a number one songs and he's all fees.
All fucking said is me. The, the
the Seattle guy there, right?
With the page boy haircut.
He was a Sadie to weigh it all these
great fucking album. Z, Gen y, k here.
Um, anyways, what am I doing?
What am I talking about here?
So something I wanted to talk about. Oh,
so my wife, for whatever fucking reason,
absolutely loves that show.
Uh, that American greed.
And um,
she watches like three of those episodes
every fucking night before we go to bed
night.
And I and I always ended up falling
asleep cause it's the same fucking story
over and over again. You
know, it's the same thing.
That guy starts up for fucking business.
He dressing the parties,
faking it till you make it.
He gets a bunch of investors,
he hands out fake spreadsheets and they
got these fucking innocent people just
go in like, you know all you know I
shy Shaw there Richards, you know,
I was getting dirty, appreciate
it. And I was like, Whoa,
it's shower was like a good Gail or me.
Right.
And then they always go, you know, this
always gets some really bad metaphor.
They invested in an ice cream chain,
but this wasn't the flavor
they were looking for when
we would turn glass in the
ice cream.
Oh Wow.
Fucking song for American greed.
I'll tell you.
And I was going to end up on fucking
American grade. Is that cunt?
Who shot that lion?
Everybody's talking about this dentist
that went over and illegally poached this
lion that was friendly with
people. I love that shit. Oh,
is it refreshing with people until what?
It bites somebody fucking head off.
Okay.
Fucking unreal. You know what I mean?
Everybody's fucking salient gas.
The pit bulls, you shoot a
fucking line. Everything.
It was nice.
It was a good line.
I'm not saying it was a bad line. I'm not
saying the guy shouldn't have done it.
I think everybody's missing
the fucking story here.
Yeah.
All right.
Speaking of American greed,
this guide page 50 grand.
All right.
That's just for the fuck.
That's not even for his flight to go
over there and killed his fucking lion.
All right. Oh, trying to
stir anything up here.
But how the fuck can a dentist afford to
drop 50 grand to fly to Africa to shoot
a fucking lion
illegally?
Just think of the [inaudible].
How expensive the shoes he had to buy
that he had to sneak around and they had
to be some sort of Ninja were fucking,
I'm going to shoot it. Uh, uh,
protected lion where that he had on,
right.
I drop 50 grand on that and now he's gone
underground. They go over to his house,
he's got a match. Right? And all they
talking about as his fucking line.
And I'm,
I'm watching an episode of American greed.
Okay.
Oh Wow.
Wow.
Why the fuck are you a phone call or fill
in fucking how many teeth you fill it.
It's guys pulling teeth. He's,
I'm telling you right now,
I used to work in a dental
office, right? And I,
there was some good dentists just
like cops. There's some good cops.
There's some bad cops.
And I'm not talking about interrogation.
Bob Brandishing a weapon. Uh, no,
I'm talking about fucking people pulling
teeth that didn't need to be pulled.
Fucking doing root filling fillings on
teeth that did not need to be fucking
drilled into because they
bought a car beyond their own
fucking needs or whatever. Their,
their, their financial responsibility.
All right,
I think this guy should be fucking take
it back there just for the simple fact,
just for the simple
fact that, that he, uh,
he went to another country and did that.
What do we got over here?
Does the MGM still have a lion?
What if you,
what if somebody from Zimbabwe came over
here? What about the MGM Lion? Right,
right. As they were recording
that you're watching an MGM film.
They fuck the police. Turn
the air conditioning back
on back on the lovely knee.
Everybody she came in. This is a
studio man. Dave Letterman had it cold.
I'm having a cold.
He lasted fucking 30 years on television.
I want to do 30 years of podcasting,
positioning wherever we live.
Yeah.
Well, what's good is the air conditioning.
If you're going to fucking turn it off.
Listen, I'm talking about that dentist
that went out, went over to Zimbabwe.
You got to go grab a Mike from
the, uh, from the closet there.
You know. No one wants to listen to
somebody. Just hit pause here. I fucking,
I never hit pause. Um, do
you know that story in here?
This dentist from Minnesota,
he's a B. You know, he likes,
he's one of those big game hunters.
You know what I mean?
He's one of those fucking guys.
I'm going to shoot something that people
think is scary and then I can be like,
God, I killed that Shit. You know,
like it went up and he fucking put it
in a choke hold. Take you didn't you,
you went over and you shot it.
The fact that you can go,
you can walk up and kill an armed man.
A human being with a gun. You could
fucking kill. You could, you could do it.
Even if he knew you were coming, you have
a gun, he has a gun, you could do that.
So now you're going up to a lion.
The thing doesn't have a gun.
So I mean how fucking difficult is that?
Actually they, her with a crossbow,
but there a reason why they shut off
with a crossbow is cause they were trying
to disguise it. Doesn't he have, he's
gone big game hunting before, right?
Like he's done at align. Well,
here's the thing that I have awesome.
Weirdly alarm is headline being like,
you know,
he's like a serial killer of animals and
it's like the way they were putting it
was like, you know, this is what he
does all the time. I don't know. Random.
He's one of those guys. He thought he
doesn't seem like he kills to eat it.
A is for sport. Yeah. He's one
of those guys to be like, Yay.
You ever hear of an alligator fucking
shot one in the head as he put it up in
his study or something like that.
He's one of those guys. So you want,
what about him? He fled, right?
Like he, uh, he will goes over,
he went over to Zimbabwe like a crossbow
and he fucking went into some like
wildlife sanctuary. Allegedly.
This lion was friendly with people.
I love that shit. That's all the lion see
solo or whatever it was. It was, yeah.
It's friendly until it isn't until the
one day you do something that reminds us,
you know, shopping from its childhoods
and it fucking bite your head off.
But it's was sort of supposed to toe.
It's a lion. Yeah. You Kill Shit. Yeah,
of course.
So he went in and he fucking killed it to
capitated it skinned the fucking thing.
Hey, what's the head? Yeah. First of
all, how do you get the head back?
I don't know. I don't want to know
that you've got to go gym bag.
You get to drain it out. They
probably do it. They're like, oh no.
You know what he did?
He product taxidermy.
Well he probably like takes the fucking,
just the skin from the head.
You bring that back and then you just,
you have somebody like make a like a
lion skull and then you put it over that
cause no one's going to note
the skull isn't in there. Right.
This is the kind of shit this
is like pat have no idea.
But let me ask you this near
because you're into American greed.
This guy's a dentist. He paid 50 grand
to do that. Now he's gone underground.
They're going by his house, he
has a mansion, sky's a dentist.
He is a mansion and he's got all
these expensive fucking uh, you know,
going around killing all these,
how does a dentist have all that
fucking money and see like a Hoity,
toity fancy dentist that like
doesn't take any insurance at all.
Like pay.
And in
the, I've worked in a dental office.
Nobody was going on a safari.
Even if just look at them. Forget
about too. Just to go on a safari.
How much money that is.
Forget about.
You're going to go over there and
then sneak back later. Kill a lion.
Butcher the fucking thing and
sneak it back. Yeah, I dunno.
He sounds very sketchy though.
Wow.
Greensville doing the
theme to American greed.
You know, do your best Stacy
Keach impression. We'll
give me a scenario. What?
It's always the same scenario.
Same thing.
It's like a Ponzi scheme and he throws
lavish parties and he buys Ferrari's and
BMWs and Ferrari. Mike. Dude,
how many times is [inaudible] Mike?
How many times is ludicrous going to
show up in the background of one of those
oddly shown up on two episodes.
Episodes of American greed.
Greedy white people love.
Hey,
fucking can't get enough of them. I don't
know. It's really weird though. Yeah,
he came up twice.
It's fucking hilarious.
Not that he does business with
these people, but he is like,
he knows the people that did business
with the person being profiled.
It's like that private party,
you know and they like show rich.
You can have a ludicrous
wrapping your living room.
I love that show.
It's a fucking
fucking missy Elliot saw.
He used to drive me up the way
we eat
and when that fucking song
pass that Dutch. Yeah,
they'd be like [inaudible] nobody
peds. Hence no, we gave him shit.
It was the only good part of the song was
when he came on. You're talking about,
so Chris was solo 12 aggregators.
That is the best part. I loved
it. It was inspirational.
No one believed in him and he said,
fuck this.
He made his own God damn tape and then
he was selling them out of the back of
the car and they was crushing it. That's
true. He's going to be on empire next to,
I didn't,
I didn't like,
I didn't like the part where he started
buying the gators. It's just like, no, no,
no, no real estate. Oh, I'm
sure he has tons of real estate.
That's a guy's singing a Bob
type of the guys wrapping a box.
That's all by ludicrous. Oh, I thought
you were talking about ludicrous.
How soon before ludicrous
is on American greed.
At some point he's got to come clean,
like going to be on empire. Right?
It's all the next season he's
going to be on empire. Well,
I'm telling you right now, if he
shows up on a third, a third artist,
American greed, somebody's got to be
like ludicrous. Like, yeah. Who is he?
Who was he hanging out with you? I don't
get it. I don't know. We've got white am,
I don't know any white guy on that
show. That's pretty interesting, Huh?
I'm sure you do actually.
They just haven't shown up yet.
I'm sure you know or have
somehow tangently you've
been involved with some like
crazy American greed type dude,
but it's just so fun. I use,
I used to do corporate gigs. I put
one of those guys went down. Yeah, no,
but not if you're not.
If you donate to a fucking a campaign,
like a white guy working in
show business like theirs.
That's some point you came across
somebody that did some American greed type
shit, like that's just how it
goes. No, I don't think so.
I don't think they go to the
funny bones in the end. For us.
I think we'd just sell out
stadiums like him, theaters,
like venues, promoters, you
know, last one we watched,
this guy ended that he throws a party
in like Indianapolis and he has ice
sculptures cut into playboy of Indiana.
Yeah,
cut into like fucking dollar signs and
then he stood on his balcony with hundred
dollar bills in this. None of the
money was his and just fucking did the,
he made it rain. He made it rang in
like, just what I love about those,
what I find that so
fascinating about them is just,
just that living in the
moment and thinking like,
how long do you think you're going
to fucking get away with this?
And then they do, but then what?
Then it's always kind of funny.
It's just a dumb shit they buy.
But then once they actually start showing
the people that lost, it's always like,
you know, he was a farmer.
He grew food for the cadre.
He never sold out to corporate farmers.
He had all hundred 70 grand.
He gave it all to
Ferrari. Mike, that's new.
They have like a nice watch.
He was well spoken.
I thought he was a nice person.
Yeah,
it's always like 120 170,000 I'd like
their entire lives and then they take it
and they go,
all right,
and they still get the fake fucking
spreadsheets and they immediately walk out
the door and they go buy a watch with
that. Like you really level cycle.
Just like does it go spend it on
themselves? Yeah, those yachts,
that $6 million yacht we saw, I was
surprised it was only 6 million bucks.
I didn't feel like it was really all
that for a second million dollars,
like the deck of the core and
everything and just basic to me,
I thought that that thing would be
like 40 million bucks. That thing. Oh,
it had seven bedrooms. What? Their own
bathroom on a boat. No, I know it is.
All that shit go mia.
Let's expensive.
Can you turn the fucking ac back
on please? Are you really that hot?
I was freezing my ass off when I came in.
I know you were in some old
lady sweater on and that's,
are you hot or you just wanted on David
Letterman had it on. Are you actually,
yeah, no, it's, I'm dying
in here. Really? I'm white.
You know it's all that hot air.
Oh,
to shake white people like
the fucking cold knee.
We do. We're pasty. We are
white like the snow. Nia.
All right. I wanted you to go, well,
I think there was a question that
somebody wanted to fucking ask you.
Where is it? Where is it? Talk about
our beautiful day by the pool today. Oh,
it was so nice.
Can we talk about fucking UFC fucking now
let's talk about 30 40 seconds of pure
domination by Ronda Rousey.
I didn't know shit. I didn't know what
that girl had said about her father.
That was the first,
like when you said that last night,
that was the first time I had heard that
that girl or like one of our friends
did it.
They came over last night that she said
something about her dead father and she
don't do that.
Rhonda already hates you just by virtue
of the fact that you guys are going to
fight.
Why would you throw fuel on that fire
by talking about her family like she
already just feels like if I
stepped into the record with you,
I want to like kill you.
Hurt everyone that like loves you.
That's what her mindset is.
So I don't understand why she
thought that was a good idea.
Strategically trying to do something like
psychological warfare when she knocked
her road and Rogan said she went
down when she got hit by a sniper,
I immediately that goes in
is all time fucking quotes.
Everybody in our living room burst out
laughing. She looked like she got shot.
She did.
She would fell over in that weird posture
where like you sort of in a falling on
your neck bent over at the ways
and your ass up in the air.
Like with you're on your
knees. Just terrible. Yeah,
like somehow your legs stay awake longer
than your upper body and you just go,
look, I respect anybody who goes
into that fucking thing. But like,
why the fuck would you go
in and no sale that shit.
Not a good idea. Well she learns.
She learns. Rhonda. I usually,
I usually root for an underdog,
especially when someone is so dominant.
You just want to see a fight or whatever.
But once she said all that Shit
about her dad, I was like, yeah,
I know what you have to a UFT.
I was actually upset that she
didn't get to beat her longer. Yeah.
Cause she deserves another like 34
seconds getting around Third Cup,
third punch. She had a look on her
face like Oh fuck. And I have done, I,
I think I said this is already over.
I feel like that needs to kind
of like caught her off guard.
I think she got a little winded when she
got her that like left knee to the body.
Kind of like cool. Not sure. Nothing
that I would have started crying. Yeah.
Once I got my wind back.
Um,
well I dunno, I can't find the lesson.
I don't see one here. Well listen,
your pocket has yours as the
Russia one and Ronda Rousey's dom.
It's just like,
it's the same thing every time.
Now it's just the same like she's
probably not going to fight it for another
couple of years. There's no other
woman that's lined up ready to fight.
Ronda Rousey is there, like, I don't know.
My friend said she does have another,
he thinks maybe she'll fight again
another six months or so, but like,
I don't know who out there can take her.
I don't know.
I don't give a shit.
Just stick somebody else in front of her.
It's fucking amazing
to watch. I don't give a fuck. Do
we look good? You have pay per view.
It's only 30 some seconds.
It's like you're watching a legend.
You're watching a fucking little and
she's already a legend at this point and
you're watching.
I don't even think she's in a prime.
She's do the arm bar thing all
the time and that she came in. No,
I'm buyer [inaudible] the fuck out. She
just knocked her fucking block off. Yeah,
this is great.
Totally fucking enjoyed it.
So anyways, let's, let me, I can't
find the fucking question here.
I like better when I
bring you on in the end.
Cause then we ride it out because
I always feel weird like heaven.
You swing by like we don't live
together. You know what I mean? Okay,
well look, you can find them.
We'll do it on Thursday. Okay.
Well here's something for
you. You'll even, yes,
I was going to talk about that Paleo Diet.
Those people trying to just tell us the
whole thing that you want to do Paleo.
I think it's fucking hilarious.
Why
meat and vegetables. That's pretty
much it. Well, I mean that makes sense.
But here at this fucking thing here.
Oh, by the way. So do you think the,
do you hope that the United States extra
dates this dentist back to Zimbabwe,
they feel like he should do 10 years
in prison in a hardcore prison and it's
going to get, he's going
to get, but Rick, I think,
I think he should be fine. Probably
a lot. Like a lot about fuck that.
I think he should be taken back.
It's some point you got to put a
value on animals lives. I agree.
It was the way you're saying he
should've gone to Jay. I think he should.
I don't think he should go
to the hardcore one. Right.
I think that he should go to the jail,
be in protective custody and through
his 10 years he should have to fix
everybody's teeth.
I think for free.
He said work in an animal sanctuary
like cleaning up all like the shit and
everything you can't have, it's like
having a pedophile work at a kindergarten.
Eventually he's going to fucking kill
some. He's telling me a whole list.
That's all.
I mean that there's not some law in
place about him going and killing that
animal because it's in there
already because I know there is,
but he left the country.
He left the country.
He's back here and now he's got to get
the United States to send one of their
own.
Now the United States,
we're not going to send the guy
because that's one of our guys.
He's got the Barcode on the back of his
neck and he's not making us any fucking
money if he's by us. I mean the
Illuminati guys, you know what I mean?
He's not paying any fucking a income
tax or any of that type of shit.
He's not walking around,
you know,
saying what he's supposed to be
saying cause he got it out of his TV.
You need that Zombie, you need that
guy. He's a big game hunter, that guy,
he's going to be on the side of those.
I gotta be honest with you,
I totally respect hunting. I think
it's the shit. I love animals too.
But I think if you go out and you hunt
and then you do it for food or whatever,
or you're doing it to learn how to do it.
I respect that. Go shoot a fucking deer.
There's a zillion of them.
They're like mosquitoes
but like to go out there and, and uh,
you know, shoot a lion, a Leopard Dj,
these beautiful fucking animals. They do
it. Me, if there was a bunch of fucking,
if it would herds,
a lions running along the prairies,
I mean that's what we would have on
his a 4th of July. But we're not,
we fucking killed all of them. And I
think there's really something, uh, like,
uh, I don't what this guy does, I
don't lump all hundred hunters into,
did he go out on his own? Was He
liked this row? We hired these guys.
I was going to say he hired people. Right.
So he had people who knew that Saran.
Those guys are fussing, guys are, are,
are going to trial and they're staring
at 10 years. Oh they are? Oh yeah.
And being a bottom.
I was going to say,
I know he paid somebody like an exorbitant
amount of money in order to do that.
He didn't just go out there on his own.
Yeah.
It was incredibly stupid of the people
who live there in this fucking guy.
I don't know.
He must've had the size of that duffle
bag that he must've put the fucking head
in. It's just the whole, how
does the head travel from,
man,
what do you do?
Don't know. I don't know how you'd
take your hand. Put it up his ass.
Like those drugs, meals, you know, I
have to fill out those little cards.
We travel internationally.
It's like, are you gonna?
Are you bringing any fruit or any
like wildlife? Right, like plants.
I got an elephant's that my duffle bag.
Do you mind if I look in
your bag sir? Uh, yes I do.
Do you have any liquids in there?
No.
It's all been drained and he's so
sharp optic. He didn't do any of that.
But the fucking with the,
I actually think there's something
fucking wrong with you if you have to go
around and killed the most
deadliest animals to human beings,
like walking around doing that shit.
I feel like that was an old
school like Teddy Roosevelt.
I'm an insecure guy and like you see
this like foreign land,
like isn't that the whole thing?
It's like you sort of take over the
people and the neighborhoods and like the
countries and then like
kill all their wildlife,
isn't it all about like I'm the big man
and I can just sort of roll nature as
well as man. I Dunno where
it's above what I can tell you.
The only thing I'll give him prompts was
as he used to crossbow, you know, that's,
but of course for, you know what, I
had to fucking laser pointer and shit,
but like I just,
anything that America has bigger
problems than rich people shooting lions,
meaning what? They shouldn't, they
shouldn't pay attention to this.
[inaudible] I just think there's more
important things to rally behind.
I don't really care. I mean, I
don't give a fuck about a line.
I give a shit about this. I, yeah,
of course I care about lions,
but I care about human beings more.
Who Do you care more about lions
or a snoop lion? Snoop Lion.
Yeah. I care more about snoop
lion then an actual lion. Yeah.
I guess because he is that to animal
names? Yeah. It's extra snoopy in line.
No, I mean I just, like I said,
I don't think it's right that he's
going over there and I'd take my end.
It's completely wrong,
but I think that in the league you should
be turned over given everything that's
going on right now.
I don't,
I can't bring myself to what's going on
climate in terms of like politically,
racially, all that stuff, all that stuff.
Why I was telling you how I'm afraid for
my brother to drag racial climate. Yeah.
I care more about that then.
Uh, Elian and Zimbabwe. I do.
That's just how it goes.
But I love lions.
Why you're looking at me like that.
It's not that confusing. No, I don't.
I'm just fascinated by, I was interested
in, I was sitting there looking at like,
I think animals are more important
than people at this point.
I feel like that's the way
a lot of people's reaction.
They get so upset over animals.
I think it's a very peaceful place.
Their I,
or when it comes to rights,
I just swim.
Sometimes we like the rights of animals
seem to be worth more than the rights of
some people. And I think
that's fucked up. I don't, no,
they care more about lions.
You care more about Elian and snoop.
I care more about snoop plan than a lot.
I got nothing against snoop.
It was a bad
funny though.
No, I just think that, uh,
there's too many of us and I definitely
rather be in a room full of animals.
I think that a room full of people.
I don't live with animals. I don't,
and I like people.
There's just too many of us.
And the fact that we don't think we're
animals is bizarre to me because we
behave way worse than they do. Way
Worse. Yeah, that's true. Yeah,
we've completely,
you know,
bears don't change rivers and straighten
them out and fucking poison them and
build nuclear pores. Fucking
animals. We're animals. Right?
Torture. Shit. Kill Shit.
Kill Shit. The kill Shit. We lie and cheat
and shit. Well fucking I'm an animal.
Well fucking awful. But in the
same sense, too many of us,
I had to choose between that dentist
guy and Elian. Cause you said right,
she was a lion or snoop
lion and I said Snoop Lion.
But if I had to choose between
a lion and that dentist guy,
I would choose the lion racist. All
right, thank you for being here.
What have snoop lion killed the lion?
That would be hard.
But what if he just sorta,
he just sorta that Leesie laid
back fucking boys justified.
I don't know.
I just don't see snoop.
You gave her a lot of CD situation where
he would kill a lion because he's not
going to, even when it's not going
to fuck with Amnon what he would,
oh cause we don't do that. You mean
you don't do that? We don't do that.
You guys like to do that
whole racing with animals.
I mean listen to fuck with these shows
about like wilderness and survival and
like naked and afraid. It's
like, I mean there was,
there was one black dude that I saw in
the commercial but like for the most part
and you can always find one person that's
going to be an exception to the rule,
but it's like, I don't know why
white people feel like they,
it's a constant like fuck with animals
or like be out in nature naked.
Like we've evolved past that past that
like why are you doing it? I don't get it.
We're bored. Oh really?
Yeah. We don't have a cause.
We're not being oppressed.
So you need to give you that sort of
marijuana way. Russia 16 hours a day.
That's it. That's where we jump around
and flip around and skateboards and shit.
We're bored. Oh Jesus. That's so
terrible. And not saying it's terrible.
We're just bored. Generally
speaking, white people
remember as I showed you that
for certain income we're bored.
Where there's a white guy like
standing like an, I don't know,
like the Grand Canyon or someplace really
fucking scary. And it's like, you know,
white people will do shit like this.
But then they'll like cross the street
when walking on the same side with like a
black person, but they'll stand on
the ledge of some fucking, you know,
clever or like Mount Everest. It's
like, what are you guys doing?
Like what are you trying to prove?
What all that wrestling gators in
the by you like what the fuck is,
I don't what I love
all that and Australian
fucking accent. And then you brought
up the by you and fucking the world.
Well,
like why I really though it's what the
nature in the fucking with animals,
why do you do that? I mean, can't you do
that with every culture and race? Be like,
why do you do that?
I suppose,
but I feel like white people really
like push the envelope in terms of these
extreme experiences in nature and like,
I don't,
I don't know because we,
we, we don't have any gangs.
White people have gangs. What are you
talking about? They're like a feral many.
There are many white
gangs. No, but like, okay,
name them Jesse James Gang Klu Klux Klan.
And that's again fuck white people
have gangs come on. You know,
like in certain areas like,
you know,
we have groups where we don't have love.
We have colonization governments,
but I should, it's like main stream.
Okay. I remember a long time ago,
I got this fucking hilarious
talk with Patrice. Can you,
can you push that thing so it's
not rattling over there? Oh my God.
This whole [inaudible] situation is,
is what we live in an old house.
Okay.
The fucking is rattled a little bit that
we run the acs for wheezing in here.
Um, oh goodness. You gotta fucking
Afghan on. I know, and I'm still cold.
That's how I got to this hilarious
RB one day, like Patrice,
when he used to just get sick
of white people, would you know,
he just would stop coming down to the
club for a little bit and then sometimes
he would call me up and
vent about white people. No,
he would vent at me representing
so what time
I'm sitting at home just being white,
you know,
hanging out and having a fucking
peanut butter and jelly sandwich,
phone fucking ranks. I pick it up and
like, hello and he just goes, Bill.
He goes,
what
are white people do you
need to say a log? You mean?
He goes, what? What do you do?
I'm like, I was like, did you just
get pulled over by a cop? Like,
Whoa, where's this coming from? Like
what do you mean what? What do you mean?
What do we do? Like what?
He's like, what do you do?
Like what do you mean the table? It's
like black people, we do this, we do that.
What do you guys do?
You go has hilarious like you say.
Yeah. But the thing about it is,
and as you answer him, I fucking
answered. I'm like, I go,
what do you mean what do we do? You just
don't recognize our shit is mainstream.
It's, it's like hiding in plain
sight so you don't see it.
So you don't think that,
that you don't think that there's
any sort of culture or anything?
Like what do we do? Um, the, all the
ECC, look at skateboarding. Okay.
They came from surfing, you know,
and the fucking ways weren't there.
And next thing you know, skateboarding
and totally evolved the what that is,
what stock card, Polynesian people
were doing. Stock car racing.
I'm not going to sit here and have you,
ted tried to tell me that white
people didn't come up with anything.
I'm just fucking do that.
All the fucking Thailand,
most advanced ketchup shut up.
I don't know. Skateboarding.
Polynesians came up with
skateboarding. I know, but escape.
I saw that documentary with Dogtown and
see boys and a fucking empty swimming
pool.
And Santa Monica,
but I thought it skateboarding came
from surfing and then this is an Asian
people. I don't know. I could
be wrong. He thought what?
It's didn't surf income from
lag indigenous people. Oh No,
I'm talking about skateboarding. I know,
but skateboarding came from surfing.
It was sort of derived of that.
Yes sir.
So saying but then surfing come from,
so you're saying white people
don't get credit for skateboard?
I didn't say that.
I was just asking who came up with
a thing that inspired skateboarding.
I'm just wondering,
I'm just wondering what this is like.
Literally then this becomes the argument
ended. Pamela. Patrice, alright.
Stock stock. Car Racing. Okay.
That came out of moonshine.
What does that stop motion?
Basically the back during prohibition
when alcohol was fucking illegal. Right.
What you would do is if you will
fucking bringing illegal booze,
moonshine, fam, you know, cross state
lines and all that type of shit.
You wanted a fast car,
but you didn't want it to look fast.
So what you did was it
looked like a stock car.
I guess stock car you got from Detroit
that just looks like a Chevy that looks
like a Ford.
But underneath the fucking hood you soup
the fucking thing up and you were able
to outrun the cops and the cops
didn't have fucking radios back then.
So these guys that did this shit,
all right would talk shit about my car
is faster than your car now it isn't blah
blah blah blah blah. So they started
racing and that started stock car racing.
That's a cultural fucking thing.
So then it's on fucking TV like so
I started listing all of that shit.
He was actually going late. He said,
I think at one point he went, he said,
good answer, what he said and
I just, I'm like fuck you.
I'm not asking for your approval. This
whole fucking conversation is annoying.
Is that car racing like something that's
very important to people? Like I said,
I a big deal. No, you're already looking
at me cause I know what you're going to,
I think I came out wrong. I'm not
even gonna get into this conversation.
I never go to go to music.
And then everything in music is somehow
going to go back to the fucking blues.
Like Beethoven heard the fucking blues
and the fucking Irish music and all that.
Like, well, if you actually
then nozzle be like,
well it all came from the Pyramids
and black people built those.
How would you know that?
Because you went to [inaudible] dot com
and you fucking read shit that said you
guys did it.
Like that is the dumbest shit.
Like that whole fucking credit thing
is so fucking stupid. It's everybody.
Africans. So that's black. I
know. It isn't. No, they're not.
All right that they're African.
Yeah. So that's my point. Yeah. So,
so like when you see,
when you see an Egyptian guy,
you think that guy looks like you.
I don't know.
I feel like some of them are really, so
I'm French, German and Irish year France.
So yeah, I have a little bit
of French, but I'm mostly
German. Irish. Let me finish.
Oh, so I'm European. So me and Italians,
yeah, we're on the same fucking page.
So Ferrari. Yeah, that
was us. That was us.
That was pasty. Freckle guys. We did
that shit. Give me a fucking break. No,
you guys invented like vodka
and stuff like that, man. No,
no. Irish Russians. Sorry.
Sorry. I don't know. I don't,
I don't know the history,
any of that shit.
And I didn't want to get into this
fucking debate as more of a like a German
Irish whiskey. Um, what's the other ones?
Bourbon.
No Bourbon scotches from Scotland.
Bourbons.
Kentucky whiskey was but Egypt now,
but now it's from everyone's was nausea's
point. Is that, was that a true thing?
That Africa is a fucking
continent? Yeah, it is not a race.
It's a continent. There you go. So like,
can Irish people take credit for shit
that happens in Romania because they're
all European. I feel like there's
a reason why this is different,
but I don't know why I said I'm
not going to answer that question,
but I feel like, can I fucking have
that written on a tee shirt? Like,
I feel like an Egyptian per
se.
I am African or would
they say I am Egyptian?
They would probably say I am Egyptian,
but I don't know enough about all I
know is that all this is in Africa.
You met anybody over in Europe saying
I'm European. No, they go, I'm French.
That's true. I'm Swish,
Swish. I'm Swiss. This is a,
this is actually, this is like a toxic,
this always becomes a toxic conversation.
Went okay, let's try it again.
No, I'm talking about you and me.
I'm just saying it because I don't want
to stir up everybody cause it's very
easily, it can go off the rails.
Then it becomes this big fucking
race. You're a fucking racist
and all this type of shit. Um,
resist the urge to read too much
into this people. Um, anyways,
I'm just,
so soccer was, it was for white people
is what you were saying. No, no, no.
I'm not saying wow. You know what
I hate about this conversation?
What I hate about this conversation,
I know it's like
I can't find anything if I say it.
Like, they can't come back and say,
if I say anything, then all of a
sudden it's this, this and this.
There's a whole bunch of
shit that I'm leaving off
cause I'll then become, I'll be called
a fucking elitist. Okay. What do we do?
We fucking pretend to go the moon dust.
The space shuttle. That's the
shit where you just see it on TV.
Okay.
That's, that's some shit that we did. I
mean that's, that's kind of a cool, no,
it's amazing.
I know the astronaut's weren't rapping.
They didn't have this space
suits hanging off their asses.
I know that the kids didn't
want but the kids coolest,
but the kids still wanted to do it.
Get the fuck out.
He didn't want to hear you got a mother
fucker out there could be a brown with
the,
I'm just,
I'm just getting your goat cause I see
you wind to leap out of your skin right
now. Uh, I
hate when you do that. My brother
used to do that. What? You just say?
Shit to get me going.
I'm,
I'm being honest with you and
I'm saying what I'm feeling.
Don't just be like you think I can't
say some shit to get you going.
I know you can.
You do all the time.
I'm sorry, I shouldn't have mots
stock car racing or any of that stuff.
That was a nice, yeah.
The thing, you know,
what the fuck do you have is one of the
greatest things about stock car racing.
Okay.
Is what's going on.
The level of intellect in the pit versus
across the racetrack sitting in the
stance.
That's why I love [inaudible] car race.
And is that why people think that
are elitist or something? No,
because you got these guys like what
the fuck they have to do because it's so
regulated now just to try to squeeze it
and then they'll fucking hundreds of a
hundredth of a second to try and win this
fucking race. The, the level of science,
physics and all that shit that's involved
that these guide the fucking egg shit
that's going on in there. And then
right across the track is just fucking,
I dunno,
I,
I went to the Indianapolis
502 years in a row.
I went to drag racing.
Do you know,
in between races they pull the whole
fucking engine out and rebuild the whole
goddamn thing in between. Racist.
There's a whole team of guys. Why?
I don't know why. Because it matters that
much. Everything has to be brand new.
Okay. I like that cool song you guys
made up, right? Right. I know everything.
Sorry. Everything has to be
fucking brand because if it isn't,
if it isn't a brand new fucking engine,
the amount of money they could cost
you that split second it costs.
She was a different, like six figures. A
lot of money. That's what they're doing.
When they stop and all the guys
run over and they're like, no, no.
And drag and drag race. They're,
they're changing the engine.
I thought they were just like [inaudible]
in the tires and like wiping off the
windshield.
No,
I'm not talking about oil
and something maybe. No, no.
In that type of racing
gentlemen. Dot. You're edging,
but ain't one of those little air
freshness from the rear view mirror.
Right. Um, you know what I'm
talking about in drag racing,
you know those long skinny cars
with the big fucking tires.
Then they got the parachute comes out in
the back engine, sits behind the driver,
finally figured out to do that. And after
years of them trying to see around it,
why they have a parachute though?
Don't they have breaks? They do,
but it's going 300 miles an hour.
Oh,
you need all the help and they don't
have flaps to put it down and you can't
reverse the engine like a plane.
And they're landing faster than a fucking
seven 47 but it doesn't weigh as much.
But there's other, that's all
the fucking physics. Okay.
And it's also probably
if they stop quicker,
they don't have to fucking make
as big as a track. And that saves,
the guy owns the track money,
all of this shit.
All his fucking nerdy egg
head shit. All right. Okay.
So this is what white people do.
They get on the fucking get off,
they get on a dirt bike and they've
figured out how to go off a ramp in,
flip in the air two times over and they
landed the foam and they figure out how
to do that and then they try to lay
it. Yeah they were, we're bored.
We're fucking bored.
Why people need gangs again?
Like if you notice like white people,
I thought we were in
all of this in the 20s
when you had the gangs in New York.
Was that the 18 hundreds of fucking book?
You know what it was.
I know I can really track.
Yeah, I could really trash
white people right now.
I can really say some mean shit about us.
Once the genocide in this country
was over and there was nothing left,
we just got bored and we just
started fucking with animals.
There's really something.
Um,
I mean I just feel like you're always
trying to like take over something or like
a press somebody or like hurts the one.
Like why I would say this,
please explain.
I don't
think it's a white thing.
It is an opportunity thing.
And most of the most opportunity
for, well, if you notice,
look at this business.
If you look at most
people in this business,
you see when they get a little something,
how it affects them.
Some people are fine with it.
A lot of people,
when they get a little bit of power, I'm
talking just getting a fucking, you know,
enough money to have your little personal
assistant. You know, I asked for Decaf,
you know, and they start
doing shit like that, right?
And you talk and you're talking about,
it's such a fucking basic level when
you get to the upper echelon when you're
talking about like,
okay,
you're going to start a fucking war and
you're actually going to profit off of
it.
Yeah,
I mean,
and you go into those fucking parties
where everybody wears a mask and you sort
of walk away from your wife and come back
later and act like you didn't fuck 40
women on a pile of gold.
Like human beings can't
have to be kept in check.
We can handle that,
that level of power.
So it's fucked up as white people.
Look if you really read a
little bit, you know, not re,
I know you read all the time, but you
read about, you know, you go over to Asia,
you know this some characters
over there that that will uh,
give white people a run for
their money and I don't know.
Yeah, well that's a very arrogant
fucking attitude. Why don't,
why don't you read it first? Okay. I will
check out some of that stuff, you know,
go over there and uh, bring up Japan. Oh,
for anybody who doesn't live in Japan
about some of the shit that they did.
I really want to go to Japan though.
I really want to know,
cause you saw lost in translation and
you're not going to read about it and you
got to keep that, that white people
reason why. Listen, I mean I was,
I mean it's definitely,
I used to do a bit in my f saying that
white people are the Jordans of evil.
Like every group has the most. We're
a, I dunno, we're innately good at it.
Okay.
Don't you want to go to Japan though?
Don't you want to see Tokyo?
I heard as I it, I love the food
and all that. I'm not listening.
I'm not just singling out Japan either
like there were any fucking worse than
anybody else,
but they got some characters over
there that have done some things well,
you know, between salted them a little
bit between like the stock car racing and
everything else. Like hopefully
you guys will come back from,
you know the break because
I feel like your PR rep is,
is asleep at the wheel.
What do you mean? Listen,
one of the great things about being
white is you just don't give a shit what
other people think about
you really. Clearly. Yeah.
I don't give a fuck what you think.
Why would I give a shit?
You know what I mean? Where's my
question? That was supposed to be asked.
I'm trying to find it right now.
Yeah.
I went easy on you, by the way, with
skateboarding and stopped and stuck.
I went easy. I could've,
I could've, you know,
I could have bought the other
shit you bring up though.
Then it gets considered fucking racist.
Even if it happened. I say, well,
we would have done that if we
had the opportunity day, right?
Isn't that what all the
women say? No, no, no.
I would have bench press 600 pounds
if I was allowed to go to a gem.
Oh, wow. Oh Wow.
Oh my God. How funny. Was it last night?
We're not going to name names here. Okay,
but after the fight, when my buddy
right me, my buddy are hanging
out, I'm in my late forties he's
in his early fifties fuck you.
I'm not going to say anybody's
name. No, no, no, no.
Nia, Nia bell. Oh God.
You're such a fucking party pooper.
That was just the generation gap.
There was fucking hilarious.
Anyway.
All right. I can do some advertising here
before you fucking all right. Oh my God.
It's almost an hour over.
It's almost over. No,
I'm saying the hour is almost over.
I have like fucking verbal dyslexia.
Can't even talk.
So you're going to walk out here and just,
you just don't think white
people have done anything.
Not like culturally.
Is there anything that we get credit for
artistically that it's that spike Lee
or some other grumpy guy with black frame
glasses isn't going to come along and
say, well actually a fucking, uh,
okay.
Pine top Johnson fucking did that right?
Originally I feel like you guys probably
were the ones that started like using
like a jug,
like blowing on a Jag as an instrument.
Hey.
Like I feel like that was a,
that sounds like a white invention.
Not Invention,
but just like blowing on it somehow.
Like we stopped with this passage.
Ways of drinking.
Like all the moon moonshine.
Remember you talked
about moonshine earlier.
I ain't drinking moonshine and then
putting it down and going, Ooh.
That was a lot of moonshine and it was
like, oh, that makes a, Ooh, Ooh, Ooh.
And then you came up with that.
Okay.
No wonder why you married.
Well,
okay, I'm going to leave
you to do advertising. Okay.
Why don't you go read up on some things,
okay.
Huh.
Oh, how smart was that? I did not take
the bait. Didn't take the bait. All right.
Dollar Shave Club. Everybody.
I've got to tell Ya.
Shaving the old way socks all la,
it hurts.
She'll lather up with cheap foam wincing.
His hair is scraped from your face
with those old worn out raises,
you won't throw away because
they cost so damn much.
Not Anymore.
Okay.
Dollar Shave Club's sends
amazing razors for a few bucks.
What
sounds amazing, razors to you. Where
is that in the copy? Sounds amazing.
Razors for a few bucks. I guess it just
can't be with that. And when you use them
with their member or members
only doctor Cabi bzz shape.
Wow.
Okay.
It's completely changes the game. Forget
foam. This stuff is the real deal.
It's magic. Something happens when you
put it on. That's hard to describe,
but you'll be,
I swear to God,
within 20 minutes you're going to have it
on your Dick. Um, it's the most gentle,
peaceful shave imaginable.
You barely know your shaving.
Other shaving products can leave your
face feeling dry and tight, so awful.
But Dr Carver's easy shave
butter is high quality stuff,
just like their razors.
It's got organic.
All natural green ingredients like
pear cactus and black willow bark.
I've never heard of any of that shit. So
your skin feels fresh and smooth. Yeah.
Nothing like putting some cactus and
bark on your face to feel moisturized.
I guess it's the juices. They
put it in a blender. I Dunno.
Dr Carver's easy shave butter from
dollar shave club is like nothing.
You've tried Dr Carver's.
Easy shave butter.
Just one more reasons to try
dollar shave club.com do it
today@dollarshaveclub.com slash burr.
That's dollar shave club.com/bar high
dollar shave club.com/bro Oh here it is.
There it is.
Mandy's me undies.
No more sweaty balls.
Butoh Doto brds me undies where I'm at
the Taj Mahal in moon up people and rub
your ass on the fucking stairs.
You don't have a care when you got
dead shit up against your balls.
You'll feel nice and covered then. Oh
yeah, they even got him for the ladies.
No more sweaty clams. All right.
We all know how sexy confidence
can be and that confidence
comes from being comfortable.
But how can you feel if,
how great can you feel if your
underwear is wrinkling and riding up?
Me undies gets it and that's why we've
created the world's most comfortable
underwear for a daily dose of confidence,
right?
Hey,
did get back in there for a second.
When you look good,
you feel great.
It's a cliche because it's true me
undies understands this and that's why
they've designed underwear that makes
you look and feel fantastic. We,
Andy's is made from modal modal of
fabric that's twice as soft as cotton.
Oh,
it's 10 times harder to read.
That's twice as soft as whatever your
underwear you're wearing right now.
Me undies has tons of colors and styles
and the only place to get matching pairs
for men and women.
They even have a new design every month.
Plus we all those poor kids.
Plus we all know that paying
for shipping sucks on me.
UNDIES has removed that
from the equations.
All orders in the U S and Canada shipped
for free be and he's even have a money
back guarantee. If you don't love your
first pair, you get to keep it for free.
You literally have nothing to lose.
To sweeten the deal.
Me undies is your 20% off your first
order at [inaudible] dot com slash bird
that's a special offer
for just my listeners.
Make sure you go to me undies.com/bird
to get 20% off your first order and that,
and so that we know that they know
that we sent you, um, also neon,
the whole all hot rodding and all that
type of shit that started out here.
That's another white thing
that we did then. I'm sure.
I'm sure spike Lee's fucking
great grandfather did first,
but didn't get credit.
What is it? All that, that whole
at wait, sorry. Sorry. Sorry.
No, like that whole fucking thing where
you take an old car and you're fucking,
yeah, yeah. All of that stuff. Is that,
is that considered cool on any level
or do we still have we blown into a jug
there?
Okay.
You got to admit that was pretty fucking
guide dot. No, it's fucking great.
MMM.
Did you really call me back in there
for that? No, no. We got questions. Oh,
he's got the question. Okay. Uh,
legals owner's going to be peppering you
as I slowly the personal computer nerds.
That's a whole scene,
right?
That's a cool scene
there is with computers.
Whiskey. Right, right. How
about the Earl of sandwich?
We came up with sandwiches.
That was cultural.
You guys eat sandwiches all the time.
You stole that from us.
You don't see us bitch. And every
time you have to sandwich, do you uh,
legal zoom each time you get in the car
too? We go. Weird family dad, by the way.
So I know it was bad.
You didn't write a song every day.
Drive that shit every day.
All right. Legal Zone.
Do you want the government to decide
what happens to your property and minor
children? Jesus Christ?
No, I don't. All right.
Legal Zoom scaring you
right out of the gate.
Not My minor children. You know what
your last meal is going to be. Um,
it's not make the commitment to protect
your family with the last will or living
trust today.
It's national.
Make a will month every
month@legalzoom.com and doing
the right thing has never
been easier.
They have created a better way for you
and your spouse to take control of your
family's future. Uh, and this is
such a great thing because Megan,
out of wills of fucking pain in the ass,
you never have no idea how much
shit you have. Right? Right. Yup.
What you really want to do is just give
it a one person. You'll figure it out.
Yeah. They come and they
fucking piss on your grave.
They've created a better
way for you and your spouse.
Take control your family's future.
A checkout, legal, legal zooms,
new last will and living trust bundles.
What does that mean?
Like the whole family
can write a will at once.
It's funny, don't laugh. No little
bundles of bundles of wills,
all, they're adorable.
Everybody's going to die someday.
That doesn't mean it can't
be cute. You Go, well,
where's wills and living
trust bundles was little.
Baby will come all we have Willie.
Um, the more you plan ahead,
wills and trusts and powers of attorney,
the more you save. Even if you're
confused about all the options,
don't let that hold you back.
You can use their online resources in
state planning tool to help you figure out
what you need or get more specific
guidance from the legal zooms network of
independent attorneys in most states.
Since they're not a law firm,
don't procrastinate when it
comes to protecting your family.
Get legal help you can count
on@legalzoom.com today.
Don't forget to enter burn in the
referral box to check out and saving more.
That's legalzoom.com Promo Code
[inaudible] legal zoom.com promo code bar.
Hey,
legal zoom.com from a burn from a coper.
I always yell hang up because it's so
ridiculous that you got to say all these
three times, so you gotta pretend
somebody is not listening. All right? Um,
come to Russia. All right. I
figured this is a travel one.
Maybe it could be into this. Okay.
I re sweaters. We invented that
everybody's neck was called until
white people came along and started,
started knitting.
I'm cutting to come to Russia.
Uh, hey Billy, Cami Redford,
you guys started barbecuing.
You started that and then we, we took
that from you. Yeah, we take it from you.
We just see influence.
You're still allowed to do it.
I never understood that
you took it from us.
What about all those blues musicians?
They never heard music before.
They never heard done it on a bubba.
Bubba.
Bubba burden are there, but they didn't
fuck it. They just slowed it down.
What are you talking about? How Beethoven
played? All those blues notes? Beethoven.
Yeah. This is Beethoven in American.
I'm just seems white. Oh, okay.
You're still, oh, you're so
dumb. My music. All right. Okay.
Can you just go move out of the question?
You didn't think there was funny.
Bompa Bom bomp bomp bomp bomp stuff.
There's really only seven notes,
so everybody kind of played everybody
showing shut up. Ukulele face. All right,
come to Russia.
Hey Billy commie red face.
I've been listening to your par chairs
for for over a year now and I was really
excited to hear about your
eastern European tour next year,
but I'm pretty sure you don't even think
about going to Russia. Yeah, I do Moscow.
It's right near the Baltic states.
I'm going to try to go to
lift waneya in fucking a,
those other two ones that are there.
Astonia that's two or three. That's
not bad for an American. Okay. And uh,
Balla Mk. Um, I go in Moscow,
Motley crew went there.
You Ready to party?
Myerscough on MTV here.
Mill hair.
Metal scene. Oh, white people
definitely came up with that. Yeah.
Dressing up like a lady in singing rock
Santa Claus came up with that and
then send it. Loves it was like, uh,
no. Not like, I dunno, it's Santa Claus
Black. No, it's from another country now.
It's not going to say, that'd be the
corniest name ever for a black guy.
All right. Hey Billy, come here
at first. Blah, blah, blah.
I'm pretty sure you
never think about Russia.
I know it's very unlikely for an
English speaking comedian to visit,
but Dylan Moran and Eddie Izzard did it.
A copy of any ins.
It probably did it in Russian.
Guys like Albert Einstein telling jokes,
did it, did it a couple of years
ago and it turned out great.
Well if you decide to come here after all,
you should not, you should bring near,
sorry, I just, my eyes went
to Nia and I saw the end.
You should bring me and
visit Saint Petersburg.
Not only because that's the second
largest city in Russia and I lived there,
but because of the beautiful
lots of museums. I hate museums.
I hate museums. Fucking
going there looking at plates
and shit. This is spoiled.
Somebody who is in the 1500 so yeah,
you can see the beginning of the microwave
on a structure and all that crap.
I think she just love it here.
I also hope you'll get at least considered
St Pete as it's not far away from
Scandinavia and everything here has
become way cheaper for tourists because of
our weak currency.
Now it a Saint Petersburg then that
used to belong to Finland and they beat
Russia in World War II,
but they were down with Hitler and then
they had to give up that part or is that
something else? I have no idea. Oh,
that's right. Yeah. Why would you
pussy riot is playing somewhere.
I'd love to check them out.
Why would you do that?
Why would I do what?
Okay. Go See Pussy, right? Brooklyn.
Put some fucking nerdy white kid that
wants to be naked on TV for six months.
That's what you do. You don't see
it in Russia where you get arrested.
You're show when clam
can't show your claim. And Russia,
uh, on the, on the unrelated note,
I subscribed to Netflix just to
watch your show last December, uh,
because you just couldn't stop
bitching about the pirating.
Like how he turns it around on me.
Like I'm the asshole and Netflix
is not even available in Russia.
So I have to use the v P N and shit.
Oh, poor fucking baby. Uh, he goes,
see how much we love you here.
Please come to our beautiful and totally
not hostile country and see it for
yourself. That's not what a cab driver
told me when I was over there in Europe.
Say, you've got to be careful in
Moscow after dark, but then again,
you gotta be careful here. Uh,
please come to our beautiful,
totally know how always be,
yeah. What the fuck for?
I'd love to see you Saint Petersburg.
I think that'd be really cool.
It'd be funny if it's a totally fucked
up city and this guy hates me and he just
learns me over there.
Beats me over the head with my mixer.
All right. Female coach
a Billy Butkus. Uh,
thoughts on the cardinals hiring a
female coach? I hear she can take a hit.
Thinks she's got what it takes
or is it a publicity stunt?
What does that mean?
Take a hit?
I think it's football. I had no idea that
they did it. You didn't read about this?
I, I know I tapped out on the news during,
during Hillary Clinton, Bruce Jenner,
and somewhere around
there. I just, I, I just,
I've been too busy to
watch anything on that.
I heard that there was a woman that was
hired to be an NFL coach, but I don't,
you know, I don't follow football. So, um,
that seems like a very big deal.
Why?
Because they've never had
a female coach before.
Yes.
But how is it like,
how is that going to
affect wins and losses?
It probably won't. I probably
won't matter what gender you are.
You like to be a gold rush. Yeah.
Yeah. But it's, it's still like, um,
it's never been done before.
So it's historical, right?
Yes, it is. It is a store.
We have Alexa. We have yet to
learn any lessons, if any just yet.
But it's a deal that it's happening.
It's a publicity stunt.
It's not a publicity,
so I'm not saying she's not qualified,
but this is what the NFL is a corporation
and every quarter they have to have a,
a show,
a game.
That's just how a corporation works
and they try and make more money.
So they have reached every possible
fucking football fan. All right.
They did that years ago.
So then they started bringing in people
like Brittany Spears to sing during the
Superbowl,
just trying to get people hooked on
it and then they wear pink for a whole
fucking month now.
That getting in with trying to get in
with the ladies to try to get more.
It's just,
it's,
I think it's a business move that's going
to be disguised as a forward thinking.
I'm not saying she's bad and
not qualified or anything,
but I just think that that's why
they're going to do that. Um,
I don't give a shit. I don't
have, I don't give a fuck if she,
if she's good and they win that,
I think it's a good move if she stinks.
Uh, unfortunately, uh, all the other
women behind her, we'll be judged.
So I imagine she has a lot of pressure.
It's just weird when you go into the
locker room, you know what I mean?
Everybody's standing there with their
dicks out and shit. You know what I mean?
Now they got a cover up.
It's weird.
Uh,
you'd rather they just be able to stand
around with their dicks out and not have
to worry about covering up.
Well, I mean, I don't think like that.
Does the male coach walk
into the females locker room?
Is this sitting there taking
off their sports bras?
Probably not. I go, look,
we gotta get out there and the
second half and shave your clap
prob probably not.
Definitely not them afterwards.
Definitely not. Not In the lot.
So she probably does the same
thing. Definitely not. Yeah.
And they're like talking to
them like there's no way,
but then that then that hurts her as
a coach that she can't go in there and
they're standing there with their dicks
out cause she's done hurt her as a coach
because they go in there and they
discuss strategy during halftime.
You go into the locker room,
but talk about that. Are
they naked during halftime?
No, but after the game you talk about
the next week and that type of shit.
But somebody got hurt.
They, it's a locker room.
Somebody's got their dick
out and it just happened.
Somebody got to take a shit at
halftime. It fuck, it happened.
I guess that's what I was wondering.
Do you have to be Naked Jessica?
You're in the locker room. Yeah.
And this is what's going to happen.
This is what's going to
be all the adjustment.
They're just going to keep
adjusting it. Okay. Yeah.
And then a guy can't have his dick out
and I'm fucking men's locker room. Oh,
the justice of it. You see what
I'm saying though? You guys
just keep encroaching, encroaching,
encroaching, encroaching, and then yeah,
we always have to adjust to you.
You guys do not adjust to us. Well,
if you're walking into
a men's locker room,
there's going to be a dick out and
you're going to have to eat it.
Fucking deal with it. Okay. Or You have
somebody go in there and take some notes.
I'm sure she's prepared to deal
with aid. Dixon are out. I'm sure.
I'm sure it'll be fine. Uh, I don't
know if she needs to worry you guys.
You guys obsessed with
us? Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
You're obsessed with keeping your dick
out in the locker rooms and know about,
you know, I'm so, you guys
are obsessed with us. Yeah.
We're totally obsessed with you gas.
Why can't you guys just start your own
shit and fucking go do that? We'll start.
I start carb company. Why? Why
do you guys always have to come?
It's a men's football league.
There was a woman's football league.
I wouldn't give a fuck. I got to get
in there. Stand next to some clamps,
strategy.
I'd like you have your fucking deal.
Absence makes the heart grow fonder
and the most loving way ever.
Fuck.
Can you fuck off for
three hours on a Sunday?
Can we just have a minute?
Jesus Christ,
the shit that said in a locker room.
[inaudible] going to get offended there.
I love it. I love it. The NFL is doing
this. I guarantee there's going to be sub.
Something fucked up happens.
There's going to be a lawsuit then that
happen years ago it happened in Boston,
right?
The fucking,
the woman went in there and these guys
acted like fucking immature idiots and
then there was a lawsuit. Then she had
to go to New York. It was a funny guy.
Have to sell the team was nuts.
I Dunno.
I Dunno where I told talking about
Dick's being out in the locker room.
Yeah. Nothing good. Very bad can happen
about that. Yeah. Jesus quite near.
I'm uncomfortable in a fucking
locker room. I go to the Goddamn Gym.
You fucking go in there. Okay,
you're staring at your eyelids,
but eventually you're going to
walk by somebody taller than you.
It's going to be hanging down.
You're in a men's locker room,
you're going to see a dick.
It's, it's happened. I'm
don't like talk to each other,
like make it in the locker rooms.
Oh, the other day I went to this is,
that's created guy. Well, this is not,
there's also a generational thing
as far as being comfortable,
being naked around another man in a
locker. Like the old guys don't care.
They don't give a fuck. Yeah, they do.
They grew up in the little rascals error.
They like the parent's bedroom and then
all the kids slept in the same fucking
bed with the dog and like
a fucking wolverine. Right.
Then you had my generation, I was born in
the last generations that in gym class,
the guys gym class,
you went in and when you showered it was
just this communal fucking shower and
you do winning there
like a bunch of cattle,
no stalls or anything.
Everyone's just ends.
There's way in there and there's a bunch
of like showerheads all around but no
stalls. And then, and that's, that
started in sixth grade. I remember,
I have never been in the first week
like that book look around like that.
The first week of gym class,
only like six kids had the fucking balls,
no pun intended to take the shower and
they went into the shower and it was wide
open. Like all the lockers
were all away around it.
The school I went to so you could like,
they walked in that dude
and me and like there
was like six other guys.
We were laughing hysterically.
These are kids I knew all the way through
grade school and they can't walk up by
butt ass naked.
And that's the thing about a naked guy.
It's either the funniest thing ever
are absolutely terrified the spending
on the situation. And it
was fucking hilarious. But
after like two, three weeks,
it was normal and no one gave a shit
and that we were part of the last
generation and we thought
it was like when we,
I remember we heard like the women's gym,
they had their own little private showers,
which was weird to me.
You'd think the guys would
be fucking more weirded out.
We were actually more advanced
than you guys. More mature.
We could all shower together. It'd be
after the first week and be mature.
I don't know if that's
what that really means.
What does it mean that we're
all seeking that you know,
you're all animals and just throw you
in there and hose it down. I know.
That's really what it was.
Yeah. Fucking animals. Yeah.
So anyways, so there's this,
there's different levels of uh,
like generational,
you know what I mean?
That guys,
we'll just like old
guys don't give a fuck.
They don't give a shit.
Fuck.
And then there's the weird guy
who also doesn't give a fuck.
You don't know what he's doing.
That guy you come walking in, right?
The Gym I go to like you can see like
you come walking in the lockers or to the
right and then straight ahead is like
the sink area with the mirror and shit.
And like,
you know,
I walked in there one time and there was
a guy standing there completely naked
except flip flops shaving
and I just, I walked in, I just, and
I just went yesterday. He really,
he can't fucking just
throw a towel on anyways.
I'm just saying.
Okay.
Dick's be out in the locker
room. Big Green Egg. Hey Bill,
congratulations on the new big green egg.
Actually he's had it for a couple of
years. Uh, I'm not by any means an expert,
but I've been experimenting since December
with my, based on your description,
we have about the same setup egg, the
guru with two probes and a fan rib rack,
et Cetera. I also have a pan that I
keep water and Yep, I've seen that. Um,
made you put on the plate setter, right.
Uh, and put it in there while I'm smoking.
All right, so he says, I put it
on top of the smokey plate. Yes.
Just like I've seen in the youtube videos,
he goes,
I'm not sure how much of
a difference it makes,
but it seems to keep the inside of the
big green egg pretty human and it catches
a lot of the drippings.
A few pointers.
Keep the charcoals at the line.
All right, that's the Philip line.
I think that's what they said. Um, soak
the chips, but don't soak the chunks.
Um, you can soak the chunks, but
they smoke just fine without soaking.
Yeah, it's Hickory. It just smokes, right?
It's easy to get the big green egg hotter,
but really hard to get
the temperature lower.
If you overshoot the temperature
is all about air flow.
The top on a slow cook, two 25 ish
is cracked to about a quarter inch.
This is what I've seen on youtube.
When you clean out the Ash,
make sure you have it cleaned.
You've cleared all the holes
in the bottom of the grill.
They can usually clog up and the big
green egg won't perform like it usually
does. This is if you're going to
smoke something, uh, for ribs.
I've had luck with the yellow
mustard spice rub combo. Dude,
you watch the same fucking youtube videos.
I,
this is the video you
showed me with the mustache.
Prep the ribs the night before.
Make sure you remove the membrane from
the ribs before you rub it down and make
sure the ribs out of the fridge and let
them get to room temperature before you
slap them on the smoker.
Usually it takes about eight
hours or so for three racks.
I can't wait to try this by just set the
temperature to two 25 and let them go
until the ribs get to one 90.
I wrapped them in foil and let them
rest about 20 minutes. Uh, dude, I,
I can't, I cannot fucking wait to do
that. I'm going to get good at that shit.
I want to try ribs in a pork
shoulder this month, hopefully. Oh,
plea out. Um, all right,
let's get through this because this
thing is going to take forever for me to
upload. All right. Uh, yeah.
You want to go? Yeah. All right.
Good to see you. That was, that was
a fun one. I love the jug thing.
That was a jug thing was good.
I felt pretty strongly about that joke.
You got so passive aggressive
you like so like Ah,
fuck it wanted that Ronda Rousey
fest when she could talks about, uh,
you know when she talks about,
I always say everybody's name.
Am I saying his name right?
Rhonda Rousey? Yeah. Alright.
But she fucking kids said fucking
dead. Look on her face like, yeah.
Destruction is about to happen.
All right. Eating help. Oh,
by the way, most of those fights
kind of stuck on that one.
Except for that one where the guy's
ended just doing the rock 'em sock.
'Em bleeding all over each other.
That was my wife fucking freaks out.
Yeah.
When that shit happens. Not and like
freaking out. Like, oh my God. Gross.
She loves it. Standing Up,
screaming at the TV. Grounded pound.
Grounded pound. Yes. I fucking love it.
Yeah.
Lunatic. All right. Eating help.
Dear bill, Bill's in roses.
Hello from Wisconsin. Ah, badges.
I'm 22 year old factory worker and,
and guitarist.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
I used to work in a fucking warehouse
and I played drums with a bunch of
musicians. How do you guys always
end up in the fucking factory?
All of their factories in a warehouse.
Bill, just read the God damn question.
All right. I've been a fan of yours
for five to six years and one of first,
thank you for everything you've
put out, right? All right.
Nothing looking forward toF is for family.
Got To get that plug in there. Okay. Uh,
the reason I'm writing to you is I,
for my entire 22 years of existence of,
had a hard, have had a hard gut. Okay.
Okay.
That I never ever been able to shake off
earning myself the nickname teapot at
an early age for my short
and stout appearance. Oh God.
That's hilarious.
I'm little tea pot short and stout and
they started calling you teapot. Oh,
you started have fantasies of
murdering all of them. Anyways,
I wouldn't say I'm obese,
but I'm certainly starting to lose the
battle of the bulge while I get a bit of
exercise from work and hit the gym once
in a while. My Diet is complete shit.
The thing is, I was raised on takeout
fast food and fried fats. Dude,
the fact that you're not a big
teapot is a pretty amazing,
they're so that's already a victory.
He says,
I literally don't know how or what to
eat or where to start for that matter.
All right,
well I would go on the Internet and
I would start looking up nutrition.
All right, shocker. That this Wisconsin
native is a shitty eater, most, uh,
where most of the population it looks
like they could play old line for Mr.
Rogers and the packers.
Uh,
could you please give a few days worth of
meals to eat to lose pounds? I figured,
I figured now is the time to get in shape.
Absolutely.
And attract acuity so I can
start to build my empire. Uh,
all right. Ps, Tom Brady is innocent
and anyone who thinks otherwise,
it's just subset cause they have to
watch their team eat shit every Sunday.
Unlike our powerhouse dynasty teams,
best luck.
Best of luck to Brady and the Patriots.
Organizations see that?
See that what happens when you
give respect to the packers,
the true New York Yankees
of the fucking NFL?
Cause they want all they want in every
fucking error other than the 20 years
after a Lombardi and Bart Starr,
you know, they went to
Lynn Dickey, the magic man,
and then they got Brett Farve and
then it's been all good. These two P,
they fucking won championships
in the 1930s all the way through.
I've already read off all their
fucking champion NFL championships,
super bowl championships,
whatever championship existed,
whatever era they fucking want it and they
won more than anybody else. All right,
here we go. Yeah. All right. Um,
well, all right. This is what I,
everyday what I've been doing
is I have oatmeal and a banana.
I don't put anything in the OATMEAL.
No milk, no sugar, no honey,
none of that fucking shit.
I have that.
And then for a snack between
that and lunch, I have an apple.
And then for lunch I have a
sandwich with a side salad.
Sometimes I just have the
meat and no bread. Um,
and that's a fun,
you know,
I weigh myself every day and I try to
lose two to three pounds and if I feel
like I'm off course I won't
have the fucking bread. MMM hmm.
And I dunno between like fucking a lunch
and dinner. I don't know what I have.
I usually try to eat something healthy.
If the worst thing I'll do is maybe cereal
or I'll scramble a couple of eggs and
then for dinner a they go totally veggie
or I do the protein the size of my hand,
my hand, a palm of my hand I
should say. And a side salad,
none of this shit is groundbreaking.
You can find all of that online.
And I tried to stop beating like
around six ish, around six o'clock.
After that I just drink
water the whole night.
And if I'm hungry I have pre cut celery
sticks in the refrigerator that I will
either just eat those or if I'm really
feeling kind of more hungry than that,
I will have like half a
spoon or a spoonful of peanut
butter and you fucking do
that and you add cardio. The fats
got nowhere to go, at least for me,
and it's just been fallen off my body.
Although I'm still disgusting, man.
I could still sit here and just grab a
nice fucking handful, but whatever, man,
I've lost 10.2 lbs. 10 point I'm
shaving down the ham here people.
All right. Boston hates the Olympics.
This is the last one. Uh, Hey,
the ability gym rat. I read Boston won
the bid to host the 2024 Olympic Games,
but the city couldn't get
the citizen's behind it.
Apparently Boston residents don't
want the games to be held there.
I thought that was weird because Boston
always seems very proud of America to me.
I figured they'd be stoked
about hosting the Games.
They root for a team called the Patriots
but have little or no interest in
watching America's
finest athletes compete.
I would like to hear your take on this
and I'd also like to know what position
you take on the, or if you were living
back east. Thanks and go fuck yourself.
Yeah. What kind of fucking more on
once the Olympics in their town.
You don't want the Olympics in your town.
You want yet the Olympics in the city
that's close to you so you can drive to
it. If you want to go see it,
like I wouldn't want it in Boston.
I that put it in Hartford. I don't
want to deal with that fucking traffic.
The traffic's already fucked up as it is.
You don't need a bunch of people
coming over here and it's not,
is it the Winter Olympics at least
Olympic hockey would be the shit,
but nobody gives a fuck about track.
The high jump and all of that shit.
I don't want to see that.
I like the Winter Olympics and even
then fucking put it in New Hampshire,
there's too much traffic in Boston.
They got like 40 highways and they all
fucking merge right at the TD bank,
North Garden and there's no way to go.
They stuck it all underground because
it's so fucking annoying to look at and
they put a park over the top of but on
top of the thing and they try to act like
it isn't happening. It's a
complete fucking shit show. Yeah,
it's a shit show when there isn't
the Olympics. All right? We don't,
we don't need that shit. We don't
need that shit. All right, fuck that.
You want the Olympics? You take
him, we'll come and visit you.
You know what I mean?
That's like that old analogy I said,
my brother taught me about having a
boat. He's like, you don't have a boat.
You want to have a friend who has a boat.
Then you just show up with the 12 pack
and you're a hero and then you fucking
leave at the end of the day.
And he's got to deal with the
barnacles and doc in the fucking thing.
That's the same thing with the Olympics.
You don't want the Olympics in your city.
The only people want the
Olympics in the city. Uh,
that people that make money off of
building the tents and the shit that the
people at the tents, the fucking
stay. Those people want it there.
Nobody else wants it fucking there.
And by the way,
they're not the finest fucking athletes.
Okay?
The finest fucking athletes get paid.
You know what I mean?
They're professional at.
These are amateurs. It's a
fight. It's sports. Open mic.
Who the fuck wants to watch that and have
it tie up traffic? All right, everybody.
That's how I feel on that shit.
Um, I hope you enjoyed that debate,
that fun debate I just had with the,
uh, um, what was I going to say?
What else do I go? Am I keep saying
it's fun? So I just plead, please don't.
If you've got to be ugly about it,
just write to somebody else's podcast.
Just trying to have a good sense
of humor about the shit. Okay?
We've all contributed in their own little
way, culturally, racially, humanly,
all of that. All right? Don't be
fucking morons. All right. So anyways,
that's a podcast for this fucking week.
Um,
I'll, I'll check in on Thursday. If
you'd like to donate to the podcast,
just go to a bill bird.com.
Click on the podcast page.
Anytime you go to Amazon, you can just
click on the Amazon APP right there.
Or would it be called the link? Go there
by whatever the fuck you want to buy.
And they'll kick me a little
doe ray me for a, you know,
I don't know what for
driving traffic there.
And then I kick a good 10% over to the
saint Jude's hospital and everybody wins.
All right, that's the podcast. Thank you
so much for listening. Go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you on Thursday.